what's your English accent like what's
my English accent like mate yeah so was
Harry Potter they always go to Harry
Potter hello mate hello
mate that's lower class English hello
mate we're live Give me the give me the
proper English oh we're live by the way
yeah give the proper one well there is
no proper one but I would say probably
London's the most normal and what does
that sound like just like this really Ju
hello Atlas how are you just like just
like this really hello atas just like
Harry Harry
Potter and The Dumbledore hello mat how
are you expell alus hello Atlas
expell Elixir herione over here
now that's the reality I'm shifting to
it's just Hogwarts yeah yeah just Snape
yeah yeah yeah
yeah damn so long long time coming
though uh
yeah brother yeah I mean I've watched
your stuff for a while but the fields
weren't ready to merge yeah the the
hybrid was was brewing in the in the
field where ready to merge for when the
field needed it most it's always service
to the whole as well like every time it
service with the whatever you choose I
choose at a similar rate like when
Fields come together it's always you
could say prescripted but also even
within the prescript is always just the
themes and then within that theme is the
Corridor of what you actually want to
how close you want to you want to
resemble the exploration of those themes
in this Incarnation it seems like this
is where we meet so expell onas to you
too yeah yeah exactly like like Yeah The
Field's been cooking this and here it is
like as a
dish yeah yeah and now the taste the
taste of it is this uh interaction the
Brotherhood and the content and what how
how it resonates and all that kind yeah
yeah it's super right and we were
cooking up different dishes for some
while like they were similar but I
didn't really maybe we we just were
finding our own little ways that we were
caught on the ego trip and then it's
like as always the narrower and narrower
doors as you get deeper and deep into
realization Things become not so much
the same but it's like less and less
variance in in in stuff it's like each
has their individual expression and this
is like what's so beautiful about the
uniqueness of not being the same not
being the absolute but in that meeting
of joy or joining or New Earth whatever
you want to say of this actual selfworth
to say you know I am free I'm as free as
I want to be now we're meeting in that
same place which sees eye to eye I don't
remember from before that different it's
more just like someone's usually more
absolute exactly yes yes nice yes yes
yes yes yes that that's that's it that's
exactly it like like the like that's
what kind of was cooking in those dishes
was was exactly that like now coming
from that place and I love how from that
place it's uh like kind of the flavors
the tastes of the gifts of of what's
being expressed and and um like I love
how you describe like in your content
about shattering whatever
limits because the the freedom is that
truth the clarity all that's already
there and like all of it's just like
stop limiting it you
know right Awakening really is just
everyone realizing just how insecure and
just how much they don't want freedom
let's be honest because yeah this whole
thing isn't about finding some key like
we're not probably going to talk about
much about Awakening we're on here for
different things
but 99% if not everyone the whole
process even Christ everything that he
taught was just you are it look at
everything that says that you're not
everything that denies that so it's one
big game of selfish esteem it's like all
this no self stuff is a stepping stone
to shed everything you're not yeah to
find the power that you are the infinite
power that you radiate that people
radiate of a Yang it's like you've got
the decades which is talking about Yin
talking about Yang and now we're in
Mastery of love and wisdom like we are
mastering at this point this frequency
in this in this domain so that's all
that we're interested in yeah yeah
exactly I love that godamn let that
[__] lighten freedom and let it rip
let it rip exactly let it rip baby H
right get it get it get it yeah let's go
you make me want to take my top off I'm
not as hairy as you I'll do I'll do it
as maybe I have a few shots of tequ I've
got
some oh I love it I love it we're going
to have a nipple reveal at some point
let's go let's go hey that's a whole
video in itself so that deserves its own
thing I mean nipple reveals on my
Instagram so if you already W
that oh man there's so many people in my
life that are finding my um that aren't
into waking just finding these videos
now and it's so funny if they come
across this just like what the [__] is
this it's not even spirituality anymore
it's just stripping like
only hey if money gets tight like I'm
open to
anything I have this Obsession of
touching the mic I need to chill out
ever since I got this mic it's just
constant like
yeah it's fascinating that that's one of
the main things with these guys people
are always like yeah touching them yeah
yeah
um okay
so yeah man I I love that way of saying
it like just let it let it [__] rip
man let that water
flow I love it I love it step into the
power right right right the power right
but Power without direction is just
chaos
so what I love about you and what I love
about this is this absolute Yang energy
but like we say love without wisdom is
just tunami without any kind of uh
Direction so what we're coming together
in and I saw some posts and I've been
tagged in some stuff and I'm just being
sort of re you know just watching things
as they come but you used a word the
other day which was I think it was
Elegance or it was like maturity or
something which is such an important
component of this letting it rip like
right do you know what's so funny
because there's been so much repression
of everyone just being yeah yeah yeah
because we're not we're not individuals
having individual Awakenings we are one
being trying to work out what it is we
are and we're all we're all heading
towards the social memory complex from
this experimental planetary system
called Earth anyway so we're realizing
we're all just maturing and we're all
just at this kind of immature Awakening
where there's still kind of blame and
projection to an extent there's still
things going on but but you use the word
Elegance but also I think maturity and
responsibility to see that we all want
truth now as soon as we fall into saying
you're doing this you're doing that
we're just turning in and going to The
Temptations of the lower astrals to just
go back into negativity but like you say
what you symbolize so greatly is this
uprising of just authenticity and a
power of just I mean the 20th century
just gave us basically a stepping stone
of spirituality you know the classic
Buddhism emptiness but no one wants to
sit cross-legged anymore like this is
not the centy for that this is for
expansion into what you want we're on a
timeline of power we're not on a
timeline of um just peace it's joy as
well it's passion as well the F the
fascinating thing about that is that
expansion that is from a place of self
from a place of lack from still
separation is consuming Mother Earth and
then expansion from a selfless
self-realized holistic place is perfect
harmony with mother earth right and so
that's where it's still relevant to
learn what one is to sit like sit sit in
it sit in it like learn how to do that
and then and then as it
becomes yeah I I just I love how we're
both you know we love that like yeah
yeah sit sit in
it no look let's let's get that clear as
well because and then let it rip from
that yeah from that let it rip yeah and
realizing that all of these realities
are existing coexisting realities will
always be there always will be there
we're tuning to what we prefer what do
we want what do you want to experience
which and and I can see through your
stories and and my choice will always be
Clarity Integrity love and so whatever
vibration I put out has to match so the
world the world is just a reflection of
what you've already set within yourself
as an intention so what I talked about
the narrow Gates as you get further and
down you can't get dishonesty through
these Gates you can't get the old Earth
ways of thinking which is always
scarcity it's like some kind of survival
your pure energy that can't be destroyed
there's no
scarcity it doesn't make sense so we're
not defeating old Earth we're seeing it
doesn't make any sense it's ridiculous
yes yes but I love it because these ways
of like we talk about the shadow
governments all this stuff this is all
just outdated it's ridiculous they must
be so much fear to possess control over
things you can only even come at them
with your light because they are you
they're parts of
yourself yeah so we're here to Shine the
Light which is going to get all the
creepy cruies to the top yeah yeah but
it's coming from an integrity and coming
from Joy and you're laughter we laugh
like this there must be so much fear in
in in a being that wants to possess
others yes yes yes yes yes and I've been
there right right been an incarnation of
that oppression and I can remember
incarnations of trying to oppress and
and oppressing others and realizing how
much that was just oppressing myself
because they were me and it it feels
horrendous and then in this one it's
just not what I want not what I want
even when you smell it it's like that
tastes horrible yeah yeah but it has to
be looked at you can't avoid it you got
to see do I still want this because it
is tempting right right yes horrible and
it's fascinating because we have the
version of a kind of totalitarian and
control happening at the level of uh the
nation states and the centralized um
governments and Banks and uh the
matrixes and all that propaganda War all
that kind of stuff and then we have and
that's kind of getting its own kind of
way of of tightening I I'm not sure if
you're aware of how uh China has been
with the way that it approaches like
using artificial intelligence and
computer vision surveillance credit
scores everything on in one technology
stack that is intimately intertwined
with the with the government um but you
know very much so like okay you are
you're you know you're either sing and
you're a good boy you know or yeah yeah
you're either
[Music]
sing or you're a bad boy you know you're
bad boy and and so I mean I'm I'm
obviously we're diplomats let's also put
make that clear we're diplomats and
where where to um holistically uh like
rage like U transform with the
injustices but we are also to be a
bridge into um the new or the new world
cities and so basically so there's that
that's happening and then there's also
the um like
the um the what you like the the way
that that happens in spiritual systems
and so then there's that's I mean these
are like the two big complexes there's
like holding power over people in the
form of nation states and then also in
like corporations and um Banks banking
systems and stuff like that and then
there's holding power over people in the
form of of of like whatever's happening
in the transformative journey is like
how to reflect most directly back
optimally that what you are is already
what you are looking for and it's let
that rip and right right yeah these like
you say so we have the spiritual
Marketplace a spiritual mechanism you
could say of that and then you've got
the government systems whatever they
extrapolations fractals are the same
thing so you see the same behaviors in
each thing because the mechanism the
same right of of clarity or Distortion
and so you'll have groups pop up which
may have certain elements that you can
just see are the same within sort of
governmental structures so here I chose
this Incarnation to really Master the
transmutation of these energies we've
done it so many times before in other
planetary systems whether you remember
or not so here is just straight Mastery
so we can't go straight to the
government right we've chosen a
particular portion of the collective to
transmute to to basically approach with
Stillness this movement to approach with
not so much a Stillness of action but
like a Clarity of light that sees the
darkness but doesn't dismiss it at not
it
it just you're trying to master
basically because I've done it on others
where it's like really [__] it up and
didn't you know we have parallel Lies
coming from the overso where they're
always communicating to each other
anyway so it seems as though we're we're
um anyway that's all context but let's
get to the content of this like I said
with the fractals so we're dealing with
a transmutation within the spiritual
Community which can only really be dealt
with by shining your light brighter and
brighter which almost illuminates all
the parts of your mind because
everything on the screen is just your
subconscious out pictured anyway so any
kind of blame is funny it's like blaming
your
hand it's like you like you [__] it's
like no wonder it hurts when you blame
things because you can only blame
yourself but that's not the bypass of
not pointing out Distortion because if
my hand was doing something a bit I
would still say right Clarity let's
bring you back into alignment with what
what you really want relax relax
right exactly exactly just like fishing
the whole day so we're in a place which
sees that and now we're treading a very
careful line of Mastery which is um the
temptation to blame the temptation to
put down but then there's also a
temptation to bypass which is it's weak
and it's weak-minded it's sloppy it's
basically saying well I can't do
anything there's no self there's nothing
to do no you're living in a world that
you choose to live in you shine your
Clarity and how you want to shine it if
you want to point out things which
aren't in alignment with you like you
know I spoke about these narrow and
narrow doors now you can't even get
through like let's say something's going
on over there that you don't want to
deal with maybe before you could just go
back into no self nothing's really
happening there's no one here now it's
like this is sticking out now you you
don't attack them you just bring Clarity
within your own vision and that has to
transmute the field yeah you know of
dishonesty within it's always your own
dishonesty anyway yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yes yes we're in a new frequency
responsibility yeah yeah exactly and I
love you know it is all your body and
then the the reflecting is around the
injustices and it's in all of the what
we talked about in the power structures
Matrix power structures but also those
spiritual power structures and then
there's the new Earth Reflections and
this is something that I feel like you
know what however you want to view it
like Christ as taking on the all of the
collective sin for
transformation
and it just at that point it's like if
you're looking for like a North star to
call God's
will why not absolute Utopia of basic
needs free energy everyone waking up
completely free to do whatever the [__]
that they want to do whatever art
creativity Prosperity play Joy Etc like
I'm just like anything that's not that
is already like running a program that's
not the absolute North Star of what is
possible for and like what we come here
to do we come here to make these
magical uh indigenous wisdom with n
Mother Nature meets like technology and
prosperity at the same in the same it's
like oh my God it's so cool your energy
gets me going like it's interesting how
we we I need to turn off my radio to
focus oh yeah go ahead yeah yeah go
ahead I'll do it in a minute it's fine
it's about to get too
warm your energy gets me going
because vibrations attract vibrations
right so I'm always looking for those
that are willing to say why not to
everything like [__] it why not like
what do you know what scarcity is
scarcity is just a lack of selfworth you
can we are just pure energy pure
creators why not have and it's and and
it's not nothing to do with like greed
or anything it's pure self-worth if
someone feels worthy of living in a
planetary system where those needs are
met and the purpose of life is not just
to get a bank check is not just to put
food in your in your head so that your
body can like Live Another Day that's
just do you know how ETS view us like
completely insane to think that that's
the purpose of life is just to get
through the day like we've been through
these incarnations and there are there
are areas of the world today say that
heartbreakingly are going through these
awful things you see Israel you see
Palestine you see all these different
areas not just there everywhere in the
world that are the manifestations of
this lack of uh Clarity on what it is
their true nature is and so we fight
over resources we fight over land we
fight over food we fight over all these
things where me and you have to bring
well don't have to but the choic is to
bring light to the clarity of this of
the nature of self and choose what we
want which is a which is is a planetary
system full of what we think we deserve
of the selfworth it's just completely
about selfworth nice right shattering
the limits that say that that I don't
that we don't deserve that yeah yeah
yeah you said we're the Creator like
[__] hell let's just go with what we
know yeah like we've done this on so
many different planets I don't know if a
lot of people if anyone's even on my
YouTube or your YouTube they've got to
be coming from maybe they haven't been
revealed of their incarnations but here
every day the downloads get clearer and
clearer even the parallel lives on this
plantry system working like in different
centuries like in Mystery Schools all of
this stuff is coming back to me now
always as revealment of the whole like
it would never been given to me unless
it's going to help this Incarnation
either teach better or know better about
the self and in in other planetry
systems they're just like what the [__]
is going on on Earth because we are
taking our time in this delay in this
reality but we've got to see that there
are there are uh simultaneity of just
infinite potential of reality we're just
actualizing the one that we prefer yes
from where we are just pure Bashar pure
AB pure pure whatever it's it's that's
the highest teachings I'm coming across
at the
moment yes yes yes yes and um I have
some of the visualizations up right now
I went through your your YouTube and and
Instagram while you were sharing and
then I went to my